the problem of the movie business today
is a problem of market crowding in other
words when you release seven movies a
weekend in the summer and many of them
have a kind of similar feel superhero
with the issues destroys a city in order
to resolve these issues the audience
begins to just back away and it creates
a kind of self-fulfilling prophecy I use
the game theory notion of a collective
action problem so in some ways the movie
business is in the prisoner's dilemma
and the prisoner's dilemma the simplest
way to talk about it is Pakistan and
India both spend billions of dollars a
year building missiles aimed at each
other but at the end of the day they're
no more secure than if they had not
built any missiles and just spent those
billions educating their young people so
essentially what it happened last summer
was the prisoner's dilemma
everybody built their big missiles all
threw them into the marketplaces once
and they kind of canceled each other out
so I'm not saying that there won't be
room for the blockbuster there will be
but the problem with the melibea
business right now is one in which the
notion of market share dominates the
notion of return on investment the
problem with market share in the
business like movies is it doesn't
really make much sense market share
makes a lot of sense in Coke versus
Pepsi because you've got a commodity
product it's priced the same so wherever
whoever's got the most market share its
winning but in the movie business you
may have one movie costing thirty five
million dollars and another movie
costing two hundred and fifty million
dollars
how does market sure make any sense in
that business and so what it tends to do
we if you're in chasing market share is
you want to do these large budget movies
you want to do as many of them as you
possibly can and often
these movies are financed by third
parties hedge fund billionaires who want
to go to movie premieres whatever reason
they are and so the movie studios don't
really have a lot at risk they get their
distribution fees and we have this
problem of too many films in the
marketplace and that is only one of the
many problems that the business is
facing if you look at the cable TV
industry there are actually four hundred
channels that exist the Discovery
Channel Discovery Networks has 15
different channels I bet you can't name
them MTV has 14 channels you know I mean
the Viacom television networks a lot of
these little channels are being carried
along as part of this bundle if you want
Comedy Central and Nickelodeon you've
got to take my eight other channels if
you want you know ESPN one you've got to
take all my Disney channels and so this
forcing of the bundle is probably
something that cannot continue in the
law